One of my friends had Rick Simpson oiled to treat his cancer and he was supposed to do it
every day and he just decided not to do it because he didn't like the THC and he basically
got too high on suggested dose, he couldn't tolerate it.
I bought some from him to apply to a basal cell cancer skin lesion, but it was so sticky
it stopped after I stopped it for a short while.
So thanks for sharing your experience.
Yeah, that's the biggest reason why people stopped the Rick Simpson protocol as because
it's very, very high dose that you're supposed to take in three grades of rice three times
a day.
You're up to a gram a day.
I think that's equivalent to the question before that person was taking a gummy that was
10 milligrams, you know, a gram is pretty high compared to 10 milligrams, okay?
So a gram is a thousand milligrams, that is enormous amount.
It's, you know, I've had some patients, I don't think anybody on here is on Rick Simpson oil
right now.
Maybe you have tried it in the past when we've had people, patients in the past that have
been using Rick Simpson.
So I'll successfully, but I'll tell you for every one person that used it successfully five
people have used it and quit.
So it wasn't that it was unsuccessful, it's that they couldn't tolerate it.
And I mean, literally I, again, I took too much the first dose because it was to start with
just a half a grade of rice and work up and I accidentally squirted out too much and I
probably had three grades of rice on my first dose and it was, there's just like I had
a detox for a week before I try it again, but that I tried it again at a very low dose, quite
honestly.
I just didn't like the way it made me feel and I told my staff, I said, forget it.
I would rather die than have to go through that, but it's not true.
I would try it again if that, if I had to, but it really knocked me for a loop.
But again, I'm very much in office when it comes to any drugs and I was just not used to
taking it.
I've talked to people and we've had patients that have used marijuana in the past recreationally
and they tolerate it in just fine.
So I do think that it has to do with different tolerance levels that you may have worked
up to two.